amo privare di programma della serata
scene un posto pazzesco proprio st over
the top st piano dei treni e cene a casa
un paio andiamo a casa un altro amico
mio ok vediamo lighters no tomorrow dopo
di che cambia location ci sta
quest'altro amico mio piano piano però
lascia proprio dinamica non c'è una
villa c'è proprio un palazzo tra l'altro
uomo che ce penso sia appena lasciato il
solito mio to the si è appena lasciata
mi sembra un attimo un segno del destino
o no ma ancora che pensi a quel
e dai 10 a 6 la pazzesca in una
serata dei trovi 10 molto meglio di lui
e dagli è però amo o un gossip
freschissimo per te allora feriti
marika sta con claudio è ok qui usiamo
mamma ancora luca te lo giuro perché li
ha visti baciarsi la cugina di marca è
esatto ma luca adesso sta con alessio e
alessia era migliore amica della cugina
di marika che li ha beccati baciarsi
quindi capito già line eletto io adesso
cosa faccio perché se io parlo metto nei
casini da cucina vabbè comunque periti
non dire niente a nessuno qui mi
raccomando eh guarda che se ti ho
portato il più caro meglio preferite di
ci paghiamo una bella serie che mangiamo
schifezze momo revo devi stare male per
quel cretino è solo un ragazzino viziato
tu meriti molto di più sei bella e
intelligente e simpatica il carattere ma
sai quante ragazze pagherebbero per
essere come te non devi versare neanche
una lacrima per quel cretino che gioco
se lo metto prestata da un pugno codici
come faccia a questo questo ragazzo
buono come bona ci ha veramente dico
rocco ce le ha tutte
e niente secondo me michele risposato
andrà fine del mese ma che invece se
ancora bighellona non amava essere
single comunque ci sta però cioè ma che
può più senso con i siamo il senso chat
e comunque vuoi fare famiglia to ciarnin
capito dovresti trovarne uno ma sei
ingrassata no cioè sei molto bene è un
po più piena un po più in carne e c'è
chi vedo comunque bene però centro
volevo dire magari vuoi metterci a dieta
tra l'altro oggi ti volevo vedere perché
praticamente devo fare una tabella dati
su excel e non so usarlo ma tu invece
sei bravissima mi ricordo bene dà una
mano potuto devi focalizza perché tutta
la questione di testa tu devi avere un
metodo ok in questo metodo mo te lo
insegno cucitevi mette la testa ma amo
quartullo c'è la vuoi fà io lo sento che
ce l'aveva capito credi credi in te
stessa change è ormai tres mi guardavo e
mi fa senza di te la mia vita non ha
alcun senso
spero che un giorno possa diventare la
madre dei miei figli sono io
lacrime proprio a non finire e tu invece
amo dai fidanzati anche tu così facciamo
l'uscita 4 ceramiche posso sempre
portati dietro a farti fare la candela
tagliamo theron un fidanzato anche tu
adesso scusa ma devo andare devo andare
a cena da lui ci sentiamo dopo ciao sì
sì te lo saluta certo che lo saluto